le bilan alors faire le bilan de cette
île interview c'est un nouveau truc
maintenant est ce que tu es content de
cette interview samedi
est ce qu'il ya des trucs que tu as pas
dit tu vas dire après à [ __ ] je réduis
dit ouais j'ai un truc que j'ai pas dis
l'asie le sait le moment on a été acheté
par la columbia qui est une grande
société de distribution de films aux
états unis sur un pommeau reid de cinq
minutes à cannes ils nous ont acheté le
film pour distribuer dans le monde
entier
c'est un truc que tu as envie de dire
mais victa pas dit non alors que c'était
là l'inquiétude par rapport à ces
histoires de bandits et 19 mm je
voudrais souligner que dans les cités on
a plein de petit frangin qui ne sont pas
ni islamistes ou qui vont à la mosquée
qui sont musulmans sans être islamique
dans le sens péjoratif du terme et on a
plein de type de petit frangin qui font
des super truc on le sait mais c'est
bien de le dire